House Democrats have their orders to
write articles of impeachment against
President Trump House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi says the president has left them
with no choice Democrats are weighing
charges of abuse of power bribery and
obstruction of justice a final vote
could happen before the end of the year
just the third vote of its kind in
American history Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill for us Nancy good morning
what's next in the process well what's
next is that President Trump is facing a
deadline of 5:00 p.m. today to decide
whether White House Counsel will
participate in future House impeachment
hearings like the one that's scheduled
in the Judiciary Committee on Monday
where members will be presented with all
the evidence that has been gathered so
far the Democrats say shows that the
president pressured Ukraine into
investigating his campaign rate rival by
withholding military aid the president's
actions made it necessary
speaker Pelosi defended her decision to
embrace impeachment saying last night
that it is not about politics if we were
not to proceed they would say to any
president any future president whoever
she or he may be democratic or
republican that our democracy is gone
the president is king it can do whatever
he wants in violation of the law her
announcement earlier in the day was a
big turnaround for someone who said
earlier this year that this president
wasn't worth impeaching the president
leaves us no choice but to act because
he is trying to corrupt once again the
election for his own benefit Republicans
insisted Democrats had planned it all
along
they've always wanted to impeach the
president you watch him at their words
watch him at their actions the White
House called Pelosi move a blatant
purely partisan attempt to overturn the
results of a free and fair election one
reporter asked Pelosi if she hates the
president as a Catholic I resent you're
using the word hate in a sentence that
addresses me I don't hate anyone I pray
for the president all the time so don't
mess with me when it comes to words why
that on Twitter the president quickly
accused Pelosi of having a quote nervous
fit she fired back last night the
president is a master at projecting wait
call somebody else nervous he's the
nervous one one potentially explosive
variable coming on Monday is the Justice
Department internal watchdogs highly
anticipated report into how the FBI
handled the Trump campaign investigation
into whether the campaign had ties to
Russia during the 2016 election that
could create a whole new firestorm Gail
all right so much more to come thank you
very much Nancy